اثناء حفل تتويج الملك ترانز ملكا على
بريطانيا بالامس اول امس وبجانب الحديث عن
التاج الملكي والمراسم التقليديه وتكلفه
الاحتفالات طبعا كمان تحدثنا عنها بالامس
عادل لفت الامير لويس نظر عدسات المصورين
وكان محور حديث الصحافه البريطانيه
هذا
الطفل او الامير ابن الاعوام الخمسه طبعا
كان احد
الابرز اللي موجودين
من نجوم الحفل بسبب عفويته اللي كسرت هذه
الاجواء الملكيه اللي كانت في حفله تتويج
شاهدوا وهو يتثائب يتمل اكثر من مره كان
طبيعي
بصراحه وهذا الامير الصغير مشاهدينا اللي
بياتي رابعا في ترتيب ولايه العرش
البريطانيه يعني لويس طبعا قبل هاري وقبل
حتى
اخواني الملك وكذا ايضا طبعا شو هذا هو
يركل بقدميه وجلس على مقعده اثناء التتويج
في مكان الجميع واقفين يعني ابن خمس سنين
شو كيف بدهم يسيطروا عليك هذا لافت ايضا
كان في التتويج بانه هذه البراءه وهذه
العفويه كانت جميله جميله بصراحه فعلا
لمتابعتي المزيد من الاخبار والبرامج
والقصص الانسانيه والوثائقيات والتقارير
الاخباريه لا تنسوا الاشتراك في قناتنا
على اليوتيوب الضغط على زر الاعجاب وتفعيل
جرس التنبيهات